نحن الان في مقاطعه كونستانتا على عفوا
حيث تجري هذه المناورات الصاروخيه لحلف
شمال الاطلسي والولايات المتحده بمشاركه
قوات من الولايات المتحده وايضا من
رومانيا وايطاليا هذه المنطقه تبعد نحو
100 كيلومتر تقريبا عن اقرب نقطه حدوديه
مع اوكرانيا الان انطلاق صواريخ الراجمات
ومن بينها راجمات هاي مارس التي قامت
الولايات المتحده بتزويد اوكرانيا بها
والتي تستخدمها في هذه الحرب الدائره على
اراضيها بين قواتها وبين القوات الروسيه
هذه العمليه التي تجري هنا بتنسيق بين
حلفاء النيتو وبمشاركه نحو 24 الف
تريد الولايات المتحده ان تثبت من خلالها
قدرتها على نشر قوات بشكل سريع من اجل
حمايه اي شبر من اراضي حلف شمال الاطلسي
ولكن تحديدا هنا هذا الجناح الشرقي لحلف
شمال الاطلسي في الوقت الذي تدور فيه
الحرب في اوكرانيا كان معكم فادي منصور من
منطقه كونستانت على البحر الاسود في
رومانيا